fast 100 tage krieg in der ukraine und
auch heute wollen wir uns ansehen mit
welchen taktiken mit welchen waffen denn
die beiden seiten hier agieren und wir
gucken in den osten des landes dort
wissen wir geht die mega offensive
russlands weiter wir haben hier oben in
der region car aktiv zwar die
möglichkeit gehabt der ukraine hat
diesen vorstoß aufzuhalten doch hier in
lugansk und internet gehen die vorstöße
weiter und wir gucken uns markus
markieren vor allem diesen bereich rund
um die stadt sie wäre donetzk die in den
letzten tagen ja möglicherweise
vollständig zumindest aber teilweise
erobert wurde von russischen truppen wir
wollen es einmal ansehen wie die russen
hier vorgehen und diese waffe vielleicht
erinnert sich der eine oder andere haben
wir schon mal gezeigt dass es die ja so
genannte horror waffe die die russen
einsetzen eine thermo badische waffe ein
sogenannter fonds 1 flammenwerfer wie er
sich nennt der eben diese besonderen
raketen hat die die den sauerstoff
nochmal verbrennen mit einem mit einem
chemie gemischt sozusagen erstmal
sauerstoff anfühlt und ihn dann
verbrennt und somit noch eine stärkere
explosions leistung entwickelt und wir
sehen in diesem video hier ich spüre
dass man kurz vor wir sehen in diesem
video hier jetzt gleich wie insgesamt
acht raketen abgeschossen werden wir
sehen uns hier sind sehr sehr große
raketen sehr großes kaliber aber und
dass das spannend obwohl wir vorher
gesehen haben wie dieses russische
propaganda video der armee eben zeigt
wie man das ganz genau plant sehen wir
jetzt hier das wird zweimal markieren
einmal worauf sie denn schießen denn in
diesem ort gibt es offenbar eine
ukrainische armee stellung und zwar hier
etwa wo sie drauf zeigen und wir sehen
aber schon außen herum überall diese
löcher hier das sind alles ein
schlaglöcher von verschiedenen raketen
offenbar möchte man jetzt die
allerschwersten raketen hier eben nutzen
um die ukraine dort aus diesem dorf zu
vertreiben das nicht zu vertreiben
sondern zu töten denn darum geht es hier
und um nichts anderes interessanterweise
sehen wir aber jetzt wo die raketen
einschlagen und das ist überhaupt nicht
da wo es geplant ist nämlich hier
wir sehen also hier nochmal die
ukrainische stellung die angepeilt wurde
und wir sehen wie die einschläge
12345 hier oben passiert sind sechs und
der achte wenn wir gleich der software
letzte wenn man gleich sehen ist denn
noten eingeschlagen sogar noch relativ
weit davon entfernt so also um das klar
zu machen auch wenn die russen hier
unfassbar überlegen sind was sie vor die
kraft angeht ist es immer noch alte
technik aus dem kalten krieg 20 30 40
jahre alte technik von der auch wenn man
wie wunderbar plant und wenn man vorher
zeigt genau wie man hier die ukraine
ausspäht man nicht immer das trifft was
man eigentlich möchte zu was für
konsequenzen das führt diese art von
kriegsführung das ist jetzt mal wieder
sehr gut sichtbar gewesen hier sehen wir
ein droh-video meiner meinung nach der
ukraine wo man am anfang sieht wie
russischer soldaten ja ein
wahrscheinlich toten auch von ihrer
seite wegschleppen und wir sehen aber
dann wenn man rauskommt was wir hier vor
uns haben das ist die stadt ruby mine in
der region luhansk eine großstadt bis
vor kurzem die durch die russische armee
eingenommen wurde wie viele andere
städte und wir gucken uns das einfach
mal an es ist kein einziges haus von den
hunderten die wir hier sehen noch
bewohnbar ist jedes haus zerstört worden
und das ist eben genau das ergebnis
dieser extremen mächtigen extrem
wirkungsstätten aber auch extrem
ungenauen waffen hier eingesetzt werden
seitens der russischen armee die
strategie und das haben wir schon in
syrien gesehen dass es weiterhin so ist
noch mal wenn ich alles zerstören wenn
ich wirklich alles vernichtet da wo sich
jemand wird dann gibt es am ende auch
keine militärische verteidigung mehr und
dann kann ich die region einnehmen wir
sehen was hier noch mal dass man alles
große wohnhäuser hier ist alles völlig
zerstört kein einziges haus hat noch ein
dach kein einziges haus ist noch
irgendwie bewohnbar
hier ein russischer schützenpanzer der
dort in dieser stadt ist ein weiterer
panzer hier höchstwahrscheinlich
zerstört der bei den kämpfen zerstört
wurde und wir sehen wie gesagt das ganze
also dass es ein bild der verwüstung das
sind städte die möglich sind man muss es
so sagen wie bilder vielleicht die man
noch aus hiroshima oder ähnliches kennt
wo wirklich nichts mehr da ist wo kein
einziges haus mehr bewohnbar ist so also
der zustand der großstädte wo die
ukraine sich verteidigt hat und wo sie
nicht geflüchtet ist vor dem russen eine
weiteres problem ist dass die russen ja
ob absichtlich oder aus ungenauigkeit
ist nicht ganz klar zu sagen eben und
wir sehen hier aufnahmen aus dem büro
netz auch immer wieder militärische
müssen zivile kraft also anlagen
industrieanlagen hier eine treat nitrat
tank tschuldigung ein mietrad tank
beschossen haben und wir sehen wie die
ukrainischen einheiten hier ja dass nur
angucken können was da für eine riesige
giftige wolke über das ibero donetzk
sich bewegt man sieht die ukrainische
stellung wo die nicht getroffen das ist
relativ ruhig aber da vorne wurde diese
fabrik getroffen die ukraine können sich
das nur ansehen und für die normale
mensch kaum vorzustellen was natürlich
auch für gesundheitliche folgen hat für
jeden nicht nur für die soldaten sondern
auch für die zivilisten die sich noch in
der stadt befinden hier ein riesiger
nitrat wolke die dort über der stadt auf
stein tatsächlich ein sehr großes
problem
zu guter letzt wollen wir uns ansehen
auf was die ukraine weiterhin setzt
nämlich auf waffenlieferungen auf die
aus dem westen hier neue aufnahmen aus
dem westen der ukraine wo wir sehen wie
ein ganzer zug ich bin das noch kurz
zurück ein ganzer zug mit 9 t 72 m aus
zone neben eintrifft diese t-72 sind
auch sowjetischer bauart polen hat aber
die in so einem großen ausmaß hier
geliefert nämlich um die 200 stück davon
dass sie tatsächlich einen unterschied
machen diese panzer werden sobald sie in
die fabriken kommen in kiel von anderen
städten noch einmal aufmunitioniert
werde noch einmal stärker auch gebrannt
sagt sie kriegen eine sogenannte reaktiv
panzerung die eben eher ans
einundzwanzigste jahrhundert sozusagen
gekoppelt ist als zwanzigster und werden
dann in die schlachtfelder geschickt wir
wissen dass die in carson aktuell im
einsatz sind im don bass und auch im
praktikum geworden des landes insofern
der krieg geht mit aller härte weiter
die ukraine braucht auf jeden fall
weitere schwere waffen um sich dieser
russischen übermacht zumindest an
feuerkraft erwerben zu können